now that you're starting to monetize
your brand it's been three four years
you're you haven't hit the five year
mark but you're starting to make some
money what financial lessons have you
learned what's like the thing that
sticks out and says you know what dude i
did not know this when i was a teacher
making nothing let me tell you now that
i'm making some bread here's what i got
i love i love your question adam i said
the first year you make money is what i
call shock money
you're shocked by how much money you
make and you're shocked by how fast
money can leave there's no way for you
to understand how fast money can leave
your wallet until you make that first
year's salary that's why you never ever
want to be a one-hit wonder yeah never
that's the worst your worst fear is you
do go on youtube your first year
successful
and you make a lot of money because what
happens is that first year that money
means nothing
it means nothing i don't i don't view
myself as successful i just don't people
do i don't i don't it's like basically
why uh i think eighty percent of lottery
winners lose the money and like shock
money except you don't you don't realize
adam at one point
you go to let's say you go to the club
you and i both like going to the club
you go to the club maybe before you buy
a table in las colinas and a little
there for 200
but now you can go to club live and
spend 5 thousand in the night
before you maybe could buy some nikes
for a hundred now you can buy
balenciagas for a thousand all of a
sudden
money
once you have more money you have
opportunities to spend more money and
people don't realize that until you
actually get the money and so to me
there was a lot of things outside of my
control i had to spend money on but i
was shocked because i was always i was
always a good saver so let's say for
example i i made 50 000 as a teacher i
was able to save ten thousand so i was
like bro i can live off forty thousand
dollars a year so if i made a hundred
thousand yeah i technically could be
able to save sixty thousand right
because i only need to live up forty
thousand
then you make a hundred thousand like i
only got twenty five thousand dollars
save what happened to the whoa whoa whoa
so you don't you don't realize that you
get shocked by it there's a terminology
for that which is called lifestyle creep
i love it it's called lifestyle creep
right yeah i was just about to throw it
back to you
yeah well what i tell people all the
time is that okay you were making fifty
thousand as a teacher awesome now you're
making a hundred thousand you were able
to save ten thousand okay so you're
gonna say all right
well you know it's that deserved
mentality uh well you know
i'm making more money now i deserve a
nicer car i deserve a nicer threads i
just you know and next thing you know so
what i tell people is if you're making
50 and that's what you're used to and
all of a sudden you get a raise and
you're making 100 you're making 80.
live like you're still making 50 for one
year yeah you've done it for a handful
of years now do it for one more year
yeah and that 50k difference that 40k
difference boom that's in your pocket
and when that's sitting in your checking
account you're able to invest your life
will change 100 if you continue to spend
that
spend that money rather than save that
money you're never going to get ahead